now it is time for puppy pig skin picks
it is sponsored by subaru of las vegas
and we have john from the animal
foundation with us with bella good
morning john good morning alex tell us
about beautiful bella
bella she's eight years old she's 68
pounds
really really sweet lady wonderful car
banners just very gentle
she was so super quiet in the car um
just a great
great dog how did she do with other dogs
um pretty good i saw her interact with a
few and she didn't go after him or
anything like that so
nice and gentle dog good yeah she was
sitting with us and our producer chrissy
so she has good manners
uh you guys have home for the holidays
start tomorrow tell us about that
um home for the holidays it's december
11th through the 31st
and for all large dogs over 30 pounds
adult dogs
and all adult cats were waving adoption
fees through the 31st oh that's
fantastic
all right well it is time we're gonna
have bella pick
it's the colts at the raiders this week
bella you want to pick a team
pick a treat oh
she went right over to the raiders
thanks bella thanks john
yeah bella knows what's going on on
sunday if you would like to adopt bella
just give the animal foundation a call
later today
number on the screen there at
702-955-5901
you do need to make an appointment
because of covid and by the way starting
tomorrow the animal foundation
waving adoption fees for all adult cats
and adult dogs over 30 pounds
and that special runs through december
31st it's the home for the holidays
program john so
some really good stuff and by the way
it's uh 30 pounds and over for the dogs
not the cats or or the humans
right right 6 40